120 yards 360 feet
4320 inches 35 privacy policies nearly
400
yes see that right there that's me and
see all of those those are the privacy
policies of the apps services and
operating systems I use on a fairly
regular basis most have been revised
recently to meet Europe's GDP our laws
going into effect May 25th
hence those emails you've been getting
oh yeah
they're all there AccuWeather Amazon
Apple Verizon Waze Zillow sure a lot of
these have been rewritten so you no
longer need a law degree to understand
what's going on but still no reasonable
human being with a job or even basic
life responsibilities is gonna sit and
read this much text no I didn't just
come out here yell at companies to make
these shorter stay down page 17 of
Spotify page seven of uber page 40 of
Microsoft okay maybe I did but I also
came out here to tell you not to ignore
these documents anymore
it's never been more important to
understand how your data is being
collected and used so here are some tips
for how to tackle them number one
understand the outline read enough
privacy policies and you'll quickly
figure out the playbook part a what data
is collected part B why the company
needs that data and who else gets to see
it
Part C what controls if any are in place
to limit abuse of that data a tool
called pollicis built by data scientists
at a number of different universities
lets you visualize these three buckets
for a number of different services you
just type in the name number to search
for key words
even though policies may have similar
formats you should search the massive
text for specific key words third
parties how is your data shared with
outside developers and marketers retain
or store how is your data retain or
stored by the company and why delete can
you delete your data the new gdpr
regulation requires this to be an option
number three opt-out where you can the
final thing to search for settings or
opt-out this will help you find what you
can get out of for instance I search
settings in the LinkedIn policy and
enabled a bunch of new advertising
controls the company has put in place to
meet gdpr requirements ultimately you'll
probably read 30 to 40 yards of your
privacy policies with these tips and
just by doing that you'll understand
more about where your data is going and
what you can do about it it's really our
only line of defense until companies
start to be clearer and more concise
about our info